das gibt nämlich neuen Familien soft bei
den Wendlers und zwar zwischen Michael
Wendler und seiner älteren Schwester
Bettina es geht um das Grab von Wendlers
Mutter Christine die starb im Februar im
Alter von 73 Jahren ja rund 4000 € hat
Wendler Schwester damals für Trauerfeier
und Urnenbeisetzung bezahlt die Kosten
für eine Grabplatte die noch gelegt
werden sollte die muss ihrer Meinung
nach aber nun der Michael übernehmen ja
und bei Instagram offenbart sie jetzt
was kann ich Vorlesen hallo Michael
falls du oder deine Spione hier mitlesen
du bist unerreichbar für mich deswegen
mein öffentlicher Aufruf nachdem Laura
die Lederjacken auf insta zu Geld machen
möchte bitte ich euch davon die
Grabplatte unserer Mutter endlich legen
zu lassen nachdem ich einen Schock am
Friedhof bekam alles was mit Liebe
hergerichtet war war geräumt das
schändliche Grab poste ich nun auch tja
was sagt Janina Kirsche dazu der Zoff
bei dem was er hört und wie nicht auf ne
und ich kann die Schwester verstehen
denn diese Platte kostet 1200 € die
Schwester lebt von Hartz 4 und sie hat
das Geld einfach nicht und wenn man dann
sieht wie der Bruder auf Instagram ein
Luxus Lifestyle präsentiert seiner Frau
ein Auto schenkt einfach nur so zum
Advent also einen Adventskalender
geschenkt dann würde ich an ihrer Stelle
auch stinkig werden und egal was für
eine Vereinbarung die hatten weil er
sagt z.b. wir haben uns geeinigt sie
kriegt das Erbe und trägt damit alle
Kosten sie hat die Kosten betragen für
die Beisetzung jetzt geht es noch um
1200 € das Geld hat sie nicht ihr Bruder
präsentiert sich in Saus und Braus lebt
so ein Leben da kann ich verstehen dass
man da irgendwann das an da die
Hutschnur platzt und man sagt wenn du so
viel Kohle hast und deiner Frauen Auto
zu kaufen in bezahlt bitte die
Grabplatte für unsere Mutter der Wendler
seid ihr selbst immer er sei pleite ist
ja auch Insolvenz du hast gerade schon
angerissen ich möchte ganz gut so mal
drauf kommen was er wirklich gesagt hat
meine Schwester hat den kompletten
Besitz meiner Mutter an sich genommen
darunter auch Haus Geräte Goldschmuck
Baguette das Auto sowie das Handy meiner
Mutter und nach einem Telefonat haben
wir uns darauf geeinigt dass sie alles
behalten darf sie sich jedoch um den
kompletten Kostenübernahme der
Beerdigung kümmern das sei so er das
sagt dass er sie hat die Kosten für die
Trauerfeier übernommen hat sich für 1000
€ sie sagt wiederum wir haben
telefoniert und er hat versprochen sich
daran zu beteiligen auch immer es ist es
wenn sich darauf geeinigt haben dass sie
das alles bezahlt wenn Sie die 1200 €
nicht hat könnte er wenn er doch so viel
Geld hat um so viel Geld auszugeben und
seiner Frau sowas zu kaufen dann könnte
er auch die Grabplatte bezahlen das ist
meine Meinung wir wollen wir mit
jemandem sprechen der Michael sehr gut
kennen nämlich sein Vater Manfred
Wessels der das auch ein bisschen anders
sieht als Michael selbst und genauestens
jetzt zugeschaltet Hallo Herr Wessel
können Sie uns
ja ich grüße sie auch ich höre sie sehr
gut wir haben gerade gehört das Grab
ihrer Ex-Frau ist immer noch ohne
Grabplatte was macht das mit ihm vor
allem wenn sie sehen was der Michael in
Amerika also treibt ein Luxusleben
voller Prunk wie geht es Ihnen damit
erstmal muss ich mal von Anfang an
anfangen meine
Tochter
den Schmuck aber den hat sich schon vor
äußert noch zu Lebzeiten weil die ja gar
kein Geld hatte das ist für heute und
meine Tochter die lügt nicht die hat
gesagt nein da war kein hochwertiger
Schmuck überhaupt nicht und dann habe
ich gesagt weißt du was dann setz das
rein dass die Möbel weggehen nein die
Möbel sind nicht weggegangen keiner
wollte den alten Mist haben der war ja
auch schon 35 Jahre alt und
meine Ex-Frau hat ja die Möbel gerne
selbst gestrichen weiß angestrichen wer
nimmt denn sowas niemand im sowas und
jetzt kommt es
sie hat Kleinigkeiten von kaufDA 100 €
da 50 € von dem Bestand da 30 € ich habe
das ja mitbekommen dann hat sie eine
kleine Summe zusammen bekommen und dann
brachten Freundinnen von Christine ein
Briefkuvert da war Geld drin was die
gesammelt haben für meine Tochter dann
hat sie das alles zusammen addiert und
der Bestatter hat natürlich gesagt ja
gut muss bezahlt werden ist auch
selbstverständlich und deswegen hat auch
die Beisetzung länger gedauert dann bin
ich hingegangen weil meine Tochter hat
nicht genug hatte habe ich ihr von mir
Mann weiß ich bin Rentner ich bin aber
noch voll berufstätig und Gott sei Dank
bin ich gesund konnte ich von mir noch
eine Summe dabei legen sodass die Weise
zum stattfinden konnte also nichts von
dem ist wahr was mein Sohn erzählt das
kennt man ja
so
und dann zu sagen die hat das Ganze Erbe
nicht hat sie sie hat heute noch Gelder
fehlt noch Gelder die sie von mir
bekommen hat um alles zu bestreiten
genauso dann habe ich erfahren dass er
gesagt hat ja sie hat ja
bekommen und die ist
wahrscheinlich mein Sohn Michael gar
nicht was die Mutter in den Schränken
hatte das gesehen hat dieses Elend
überhaupt
ihre Tochter hat kein
Geld dazu gegeben
was ich ihm sagen würde er möchte ich
überhaupt gar keinen Kontakt zu ihm
haben werde ich auch nicht aber ich gehe
mal was auf dem Weg mit dass er sich
dermaßen schämen soll aber gibt ja
sowieso nichts drum er gibt nichts dann
rum er krault sich die Füße am Strand
lässt sich gut gehen gibt Geld aus das
kennt man ja von ihm und alles andere
ist Luft sind Luftblasen und der Tag
wird kommen
davon bin ich 100% überzeugt dass er die
Retourkutsche bekommt der Tag wird
kommen, können Sie mir glauben und das
werde ich noch miterleben trotz meines
Alters von 74 Jahren die wird nächstes
Jahr 75 Jahre und der Herrgott der lässt
wir noch weil ich noch alles miterleben
werde und der findet keine Ruhe solange
sein Vater lebt
ihr Sohn hat gerade ein neues
Geschäftsmodell für sich entdeckt und 2
gibt es eine Plattform onlyfans dieser
mit nackter Haut wirkt wo er und seine
Frau jetzt sozusagen für 35 € Monat kann
man ein Abo anschließen und da kann man
einen Einblick in die Welt der Wendlers
bekommen teilweise gibt es da auch ja
Bilder wo Laura ihren halbnackten Po
zeigt und er sehr auf darauf klatscht
wie geht es Ihnen als Vater wenn sie
sowas sehen und so was über ihren Sohn
lesen und auch mitbekommen
und Schublade ich bin nach wie vor davon
überzeugt dass er zwei Amerika mit dir
verheiratet ist hier in Deutschland
nicht ob die geschiedenen ist immer noch
eine andere Sache was ich auch noch
nicht glaube und was er da macht das ist
unterste Schublade sowas kenne ich nicht
und sowas will ich auch nicht
kennenlernen das ist das allerletzte das
allerletzte was er sich erlaubt es jetzt
viele Leute die noch da drauf geht und
noch dies aber bitte
verstehe ich die Welt nicht mehr danke
für diese emotionalen Worte und wir
hoffen dass es vielleicht in diesem
Streit doch irgendwann noch mal ein
gutes Ende geben wird vielen vielen Dank
ihn
nein es gibt kein gutes Ende noch mal
auf diese Grabplatte zurückzukommen
sie hat mein Enkelkind anneleen
angeschrieben sie sollen ihren Vater
sagen dass gerade die furchtbar aus es
muss eine Platte drauf so und er kam
nicht mal mit einem Wort raus oder hat
sie kontaktiert daraufhin hat sie ein
Hilferuf gestartet über das Instagram
mit recht vielleicht wird das ja noch
recht dass er
kommt wir danken ihn jedenfalls wir
haben ein bisschen Zeit Note danke für
das Gespräch Herr Wessels